[Music]
his hands were once used for battle
now they've got humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
[Music]
exactly who i am
[Music]
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment
[Music]
my superheroing days are over
[Music]
remember what i told you
[Music]
you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am gonna get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
see not so bad
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
is our fortress
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain let you ready as i'll ever
be commander hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you
come right back to us to infinity and
beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
hey
the what
what is happening right now alicia oh no
that's my grandmother but sucks how long
were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was gonna be like a
fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the
[Music]
harpoons right
[Music]
the here of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 percent seems
a bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a bed don't at least record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of proceeds
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
[Music]
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evelyn's
you can access all the memories their
emotions
even the skills
there's a great evil spreading about the
many verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
ah that looks really good
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of senseless things is so much
bigger
than
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
motives
there is no way i am the everlane you
are looking for
every rejection
every disappointment has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
every
night i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wonder
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look up
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
right
[Music]
oatmeal latte light foam
hey
how's uh the mars boyfriend long
distance dating sucks how long have you
guys been together eight years eight
years how did you manage that he checks
all the boxes oh you mean literally
strong jaw mental fortitude six-pack
we had a plan and then he got his
martian dream job
so i enrolled in the mars program
you ever worry the wrong person is
headed to the wrong planet goodbye
forever walt
five
four
three
two
hello hey
what are you doing here who sneaks onto
spaceships i can explain
ever since i was a kid i dreamt of going
to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys i'm your captain this
is sophie my girlfriend long-term
girlfriend i don't remember you from
orientation
what happened
you have to come right back and just rip
his jumpsuit off
[Laughter]
hey what's up i just miss you sorry do
we have a call scheduled
come on let's go have some fun i don't
do fun you also don't fly on rockets or
conspire with stowaways sophie for walt
disney 100 bucks since you just said
that in your wrist you just got to face
it you're a space criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful
now that is a story people want to hear
you've spent your entire life trying to
check an impossible set of foxes
i can't risk the plan when you find that
thing that you're willing to cross the
entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel you
can never escape yourself did you just
come up with that no [ __ ] that is a
very common phrase
[Music]
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizen you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
you are really bad at punching
[Music]
you don't make it easy
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it it
is but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
wanna get out of here
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it is time to stop seeing
[Music]
it is time to stop speaking
[Music]
it is time
to listen
it is time to stop seeing
it is time to stop speaking
it is time
to listen
listen
listen
[Music]
[Music]
they say these are crazy times
everyone out for themselves
and one day i got a chance to sell my
soul and i took
it would you lie to you with me when
[Music]
you know what love is jack i've only
heard stories from a long time ago
you recently had any new type of
experience
like one
you got the girl
why are they falling
the corporation won't stop until it has
you
the only chance is to stop seeing the
girl
what if i can't stay away from her
then
you will die
there isn't much time
in deteriorating quickly
these people are very
dangerous and you should walk away
[Music]
you ever been scared
[Music]
[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
youtube plays immediately three bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic i'm not facing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
you have got a big gravity weight coming
your way you have to launch now did he
say gravity wave
trouble
we're underwater guys
uh that's crazy
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
right what are you doing
it's flying itself
wait for it
[Music]
hang on
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
the family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat in the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend to yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
you lied to me
we all have our scars bruce he's still a
wine
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know she's up with
delaney
where are you under there
what are you hiding selena you'll throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may
find justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
what you do to batman come
you don't know what's out there
it was bad
very
bad
[Music]
[Music]
it's not safe here
[Music]
define us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what threatened us with catastrophe
turned out to be our salvation
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and the earth was cycles and empty
and the darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline in the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
[Music]
if we don't stand up no one
will come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
[Music]
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
it's up to us to control it
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
this work is incredible well that's my
favorite part about taking photos you
wander and find places like this it
makes me a little delirious i like what
your eyes are doing to me right now
it's really cheesy no it was um a little
cheesy um maybe i'll see you here again
sometime
you said he was cute
emojis are cute that guy is melting my
sunglasses tess
i think you could sell this stuff but
there is something that's missing from
like all of your photos you
i love you jose
welcome back to the world of the living
[Music]
i just wish i could see him one more
time even for a minute
he loved him and he knew that
[Music]
[Music]
what is happening when the separation is
dramatic there's unfinished business
he's in the in between
he's reaching out to you
reach back your ghost hunting assistant
has arrived a ouija board
oh my god
sorry that was me
if you do manage to cross there may be
no way back
here
i'm gonna find him
[Music]
i'm still here
[Music]
come on yank
what are you doing
come on
[Music]
what happened to yang i don't know
shut down last night he won't restart
does this happen before no
[Music]
if we can't get young fixed
[Music]
i'm not gonna buy another sibling for
mika
[Music]
it is an interior core problem
i need your permission to break open the
core
we've always known that some bots are
equipped with spyware
you might not want this part in your
house anymore
i wish i had a real memory
what do you mean
[Music]
did you want to be human
that's such a human thing to ask isn't
it
[Music]
may i be honest with you wait
it's not being honest an option for you
[Music]
do you want him back of course i do
i want him back too
i just need a little more time
[Music]
what are you watching
come on
[Music]
[Music]
you